hey everyone it's mikee from morals here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you could join me for today's video
we're going to dive deeper into you know
sort of a footprint chart versus uh a
normal Candlestick chart and you know
sort of the reason why this video you
know the purpose behind this video is
because you know sort of a uh a comment
that came up uh a couple days ago from
uh
kasoon chamara 749 I hope I got that
name right kassoon uh chamara now I I
know he didn't mean any disrespect you
know I know he's a he's a follower of
mine and but I just found this a very uh
important topic to discuss um because
you know he said he started out with
another art broken flow guy because of
ICT yeah I as I said I'm not butt hurt
or anything like that um but he says
show us your performance without
footprint range chart or any kind of
volume tools ICT always shows his
performance through naked charts um can
you do the same performance without
volume tools PS uh ICT never says volume
tools are useless instead says they are
good tools uh but practice eyes for
tracking institutional Footprints
through naked chart I'm also using
volume tools to prove myself how
accurate is Michael Hon's liquidity
concept and all the time I see his
concepts are freaking good and working
any time frame in any instruments and
like I I replied um to kasun and you
know I said I'm not heartbroken you know
there is some value in ICT stuff right
there's many different ways to trade
theet markets no one way is the best
instead what's best is for the
individual Traders right I prefer to
look at volume to determine where
there's really an imbalance you know to
each their own and you know to cun's
credit he did come back and explain
further saying um you know no no
disrespect or anything he does find a
lot of value in what I teach and you and
he gets it right and K also understands
the importance of volume and you know
this is important because there's so
many different ways to trade out there
and really what you got to do sometimes
you know is you got to take stuff from
one method of trading and a different
method of trading and sort of fuse them
together into a way that you could
understand the market best all right and
I'll be honest with you let me get this
down let me get this out of the way I
can't
look I mean I could look at a foot at a
at a normal Candlestick chart and and
trade this I mean there are certain
patterns that I'm looking for on um you
know on candlesticks right I mean this
is you know I got you know to me this
would be a buy area right here um but to
be
honest I find my Edge comes through
looking
at the volume right at the footprint
where the value areas are where there's
point of controls that matter where the
imbalances come and again I'm not
knocking ICT stuff I I just get a
chuckle at it sometimes because you know
I see guys on Twitter saying yeah there
was an there's an imbalance here I'm
like okay how how can you see that uh
just by looking at you know a bar like
this right a fair value Gap um okay yeah
I mean I I I know that you and this work
gets interesting because if I were to
look at okay so for example here if we
call this a fair value Gap right here 19
uh 4720 to uh 4650 you know when I got a
big bar down like this there there are
going to be imbalances in there you know
just by by uh default that's what time
was this was uh
10:07 uh yeah you got one imbalance in
here obviously you got a fair value gap
between this bar and this bar as well
but you see yeah there are imbalances
you know anytime you're going to have a
longy g a long stretched out bar in a
market this is gold you you generally
you are going to have an imbalance in
there at least one all right but okay so
you sort of get the ideas now again at
the end of the day it comes down to what
helps you as a Trader really wrap your
head around the market because you know
if I was just looking at a simple
Candlestick chart without
volume then at that point I'm looking at
Price patterns okay but I know that for
me when I'm looking at Price patterns
and then I could add volume into the mix
I mean actual
volume it just helps me out more and
there's nothing wrong with it you know I
lived in Singapore for about 10 years
and you know as as an American going
over there I'm used to you're sick you
go see the doctor you know maybe does
you know you got to you know they'll do
an x-ray on you and tell you what's
wrong my friends used to take me to this
guy he he would just take your
pulse and tell you what's wrong with you
you know he doesn't need an x-ray so
there you know just and he would he
would prescribe you know the TCM the
traditional Chinese medicine for you you
know you need some of the you know I
don't say I of n or whatever but you
know you got to eat these bugs you you
don't just eat them but rather you make
them into like a a drink and then then
you drink it like the different herbal
leaves and things like that
but what I'm saying is you know Western
doctors have a way of looking at a
patient determining what's wrong with
him or let me rephrase that look at a
patient tell me what's going on with the
patient's overall health whereas you
know sort of the tradition Chinese
medicine doctors will take your pulse
you know and and and by taking your
pulse right they're measuring your your
sort of blood flow and all that and then
they can tell you what's wrong with you
okay now it do you know you have to at
the same time you sort of got to believe
what they're doing you know each doctor
you know knows the right way but that's
not to discredit one or over the other
right I mean the the Chinese doctor
he'll probably look at an x-ray can't
make anything of it
fine that doesn't mean that he's not a
good doctor all right so there's there's
many different ways to trade and
approach the market now you know that
being
said you know over the you know I I have
an indicator I've never released you
know people always ask me about a lot
because they see in my charts here
there's a lot of indicators right
there's a lot of indicators I haven't
released um some of them you know just
things that I've I've worked on off and
on over the years I've had my my
programmer make stuff um because I was
looking for certain thing but I actually
have one here it's called the bar gaps
indicator
and let me just
uh add it in here but you know it's it's
kind of loosely based off of fair value
gaps but what I've done is I've taken
sort of that idea of you know sort of
price moving all right cuz yeah I do
understand the whole concept of IC fair
value gaps and but when I start to add
it together with order
flow Right add what I look at in the
market into something like that it in my
opinion makes me a better Trader in a
way makes me understand the markets more
right it might be a little bit hard here
to see the little arrows well let me
just make them a little bit bigger
here cuz you know at the end of the day
right there's like I said you know a big
believer in this there's no one white
right way to
trade right and you know so you can see
even though now this is where it gets
interesting know there's some fair value
gaps what I call Bar gaps right gaps
taking place that I think are more
tradable than others right so you can
see like a Zone here you know I didn't
give a signal the triangles areas where
you're going to get long or short right
um that just you know now I've added in
what I know about actual orderflow
volume that's taking place in the
footprint that can because like for
example right if I see a certain thing
happening in the volume taking
place um you know in the footprint yeah
it's going to give
me a high percentage trade and if I
could wrap that around um you know some
sort of price action because you know at
the end of the day really what the fair
value Gap is is price action
right it's a bar and you have a gap you
know you have a the big bar moving you
know from the the high of one bar to the
low of the third bar so bar one bar two
bar
three you know and you're going to see
areas where you know they you know
here's a gap that went down right but
here's another Gap that went down didn't
really work so by adding the extra
element of looking at
volume looking at the
actual trading that's taking place
between the aggressive buyers and the
aggressive sellers right I could take a
price action um setup and make it into
you know something that's more useful
for me okay because again you're not
going to just want to take every sort of
fair value Gap that you see taking place
in the market I mean I mean you could
all right but then you know you're going
to have winners and losers you want in
my opinion you know you want to sort of
take the best ones right I mean that
that's what trading is all about right
you want to take the the higher
percentage trades um that are coming
right I mean here's Euro currency
okay
so at the end of the day you know
getting back to uh consum
comments I can't show you performance
without footprint chart range charts or
any kind of volume tools because that's
something that I lean on that's where I
find my advantage in the market okay you
know just think of it you know playing
poker some guys can read tells great
some guys can do the the math in their
head great doesn't mean one way is
better than the other obviously if you
can read uh someone's tells as well as
do the math in your head that's going to
make you a stronger
player so again at the end of the day
you know trading is about taking what is
available the information that's
available to
you and using it to your
advantage okay because at the end of the
day we all want to have an edge in the
markets sometimes our Edge comes from
this place or or that place and you got
to put it together that's where you're
going to succeed as a market I I've
worked with guys right there's a guy I
can't remember his name now it's so
long at at Commerce Bank but he was like
this Prodigy kid where you know 22y old
kid out of college he made like 20 this
was back in the 90s right guy made like
$20 million or something like that as a
beginning Trader at Comer B $20 million
back in the 90s was a lot of money for a
Trader to make especially a beginning
Trader and he felt like he got screwed
on his bonus and he left but he is
somebody you know I could talk to him I
really can't remember his name but he
can take macro information and sort of
see where the market would be six months
in the future it's something like
something so tiny little piece of
information hoof and mouth disease in
Essex County
and in London or something like that and
say okay this is where I expect guilts
to be off of that you know but whatever
he had his way of approaching the market
like I said there's no one right way of
approaching the market really what you
got to do is you you really got to blend
stuff together sometimes right to make
the market make sense to you so again
you know again Cen shout out to you I I
appreciate your comment I I know there's
no disrespect um and and I appreciate
comments like that because it gets a
dialogue going
so Traders can understand because a lot
of newer Traders come into the market
and they watch someone trade or they
follow them on Facebook or Twitter this
is
it and you know and it's like if you
don't if you don't agree with it they
beat you down or they call you a hater
and stuff like that but really what
trading is it's just making the market
make sense to you because everyone's got
a different mindset everyone's got a
different
way to approach the
market all right and it's about finding
what works for you so again you know if
I was looking at a normal Candlestick
chart like this yeah there are patterns
I can see that I'm always looking
for right based off of price but when
I'm able to wrap it around with volume
tools to me that just gives it makes the
market you know in my opinion to me make
perfect sense so that I can trade it
confidently cuz you know again you want
to be confident in your trading you
don't want to be sitting here oh you
know is this is that um you want to be
sure about what you're looking at and
trading
it so anyway guys you know that's going
to wrap up this video again you know
keep those comments coming I I do
appreciate it because you know it's one
of it's comments like that that you made
um K that helps Traders
understand the markets that there's more
than one way to look at a market and
again I I see you know I see comments
you know people someone commented on um
you know I'm struggling
trading people told me I have to look at
this type of
chart well that type of you know like I
don't know what I forgot what it was
five range NQ chart and if you're new to
trading looking at a five range NQ chart
is very difficult for a lot of Traders
especially new
Trader because it's moving very fast
right if you don't understand that it's
moving very fast it's going going be
difficult to trade you know you're going
to find yourself getting late getting
into moves late buying a
high and selling it at the low right
because you got in late because you
don't understand that a five range chart
on NQ is a very fast moving
chart so that's why I appreciate these
comments um you know even though this
wasn't necessarily an order flow related
video I thought it was a very um
important topic for Traders to
understand and you know sort of wrap
their heads around so again thanks
everyone for being a part of my
community listening to my uh my comments
and my rants sometimes uh if you enjoyed
this video be sure to hit that like
button and subscribe to my channel so
you don't miss any more of my upcoming
videos and again keep those comments
flowing you know I I I'm trying to be
more proactive on on actually making
videos about the comments because you
know these are these are very valid
points that need to be addressed by
Traders because you know a lot of videos
will just say hey you know this is the
way you're suppos to trade do this do
that it's not about that trading is a
thinking game I I want you to think as
well so all right everyone I'll catch
you guys on the next video
bye-bye